oh [__] you're beautiful [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning you bad [__]
Friday December 9th it's pay day so you
gotta get up unless it's not [__]
paid day we get up anyway just a swing
dick and give up [__] bubblegum
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle Joey here we had a big week this
week Rogen Louie Gomez Ashley Barnhill
does she's so special that was time to
sit back smoke a few bowls and hang out
with your [__] family that's it
that's the [__] they give to Cubans
after they make the 90-mile [__] Trek
but anyway we're here with we're you got
a job to do you got love to swing you
got to make somebody's day so get the
[__] out there and do it that's the most
important thing and no matter how bad
you [__] feel today what that make
somebody's dick
drop a [__] button give them two
bucks at the 7-eleven watch their
[__] faces I feel like a Stevie on
Friday I'm saying
but Joey enough with the chitty-chat
let's smoke some [__] reef a
little really understood that I can't
argue with you then oh I'm still coming
down off that 1,800 [__] spars we ate
last night god damn I got all my Hannity
to [__] him how to drink a protein shake
like full [__] Christmas could be
second taking them well thank God I
passed the [__] out
but listen yesterday we broke the
[__] seaso computer they called up
and said stop stop we can't take much of
guys thank you for the bottom of my
heart this means the world to me I'm a
flop getting fat [__] an ex-felon loser
and we put this together as a [__]
team six years started with Beauty and
the Beast you know now we got the church
dropped and [__] my hard-on you
[__] don't you what I went
through
look at this [__] weed I didn't break
it up yet look at pretty this is look at
this on a Friday [__] bomb look I'm
showing you [__] look at what
brings this tree on a Friday but I'm
pretty what a nice exotic little [__]
thought that's what I'm talking about
today I'm gonna go to jujitsu
I got a little meet with some people at
2:30 and I said like I said I'm taking
the week off and stand up to reprogram
the [__] mind
get him saying and I'm back out there
Tuesday night I'm half factory with
gamma Reverend [__] bill burr and the
rest of us [__] savages
okay yes I will be a [__] to
get to today it'll be my second time
this week
I don't know satellite just keep up so
what so what
who gives a [__] you get to jumping up
buildings being a burglar just keep
showing up cut suckers write your goals
down specify what you want in your life
and how you gonna get it and watch it's
up and appear how do I know I'm [__]
living it [__] planes trains and
automobiles [__] you know I'm
saying bless a little reefer a little
love and you can't suck this we can't go
wrong remember I'm with you you're with
me and they're with us as well let's put
together we have the strength of 10 dead
[__] savages you follow me we show up
all at once if you see so yesterday we
can't take it stop downloading that's
the power that we [__] have as Savage
one more ball what the [__] will you
talk [__] Friday morning huh I did one
bone they can't feel my legs who gives a
[__] that's the purpose of this [__]
[Music]
let's do one more
what the [__] you doesn't saying you
know us we don't stop we take it to the
hell we push the [__] that boom
you're not gonna push the envelope go on
pull yourself somebody's dick and ended
too young Sam you gotta push the [__]
and blow up every day at every level of
your [__] life push it
I'm a back button I usually last a row
maybe two [__] rows when I go - did
you - but you know what I always get
back in there two more minutes and then
tomorrow one more minute then the day
after that one more minute and pretty
soon look what the [__] you built on
your own it's time brother it's all
about time give it time
plant the seed water it give it love and
watch that [__] dream of yours
come up forget about it
and you're gonna bump your [__] and
jump up and down with other [__] is
that you want to do but at least you'll
have peace of mind you follow me this
weeds good thing I'm talking a lot of
[__] anyway
the podcast is up and Lily Gomez lastly
wanna see so is ready for you or you
have news pressing jump your help which
is most important and you got a little
[__] food to loose everything a
little prayer for Tommy's that
[__] driving across country in
the van a debt right now he's probably
getting torn into a [__] Porter
I'm gonna go see [__] The Wizard of
Oz [__] but anyway I love you guys
with all my [__] heart see you Sunday
night for a podcast 6 o'clock
besides that stay strong I love you and
I'll do another one of these maybe
tomorrow morning maybe later I have a
big game don't take no [__] from nobody
today you put your pants on one leg at a
time like the rest of these
[__] ain't no better than you
suck your dick and call you sure do you
get their mom and my beta that DC gets a
great time I'm over on the higher
whatever I love you [__] don't
take [__] from nobody keep the eyes open
remember they could all suck your dick
stay black uncle Joey loves you